[Music]
tines day I'm just curious what did you
ladies do for Valentine's Day it just
passed recently and it was one year that
I've been been engaged so it's kind of
like you know a nice dinner for us okay
so you just went out to dinner yeah
what about you JWoww same the gen Roger
call asleep just watch her like it that
you go around telling everybody that you
that you don't have sex and that he's a
narc laughter I'm turning it around I'm
turning around because the big joke like
Roger likes to joke like with Jionni
it's the short jokes with me it's a no
sex jokes so now I'm just gonna be open
with him like yeah well if you didn't
fall asleep at the time maybe you'd get
it in or cut
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies it calms me sometimes to look at
the ocean think about sex every seven
seconds so technically I would have that
sex with them like 15 times already on
the show oh yeah exactly what men do you
think about sex constantly
and what that changes over time over
time it becomes other things you know
like what baseball politics
no no just like cheese products how am I
gonna swing a nap where am I gonna take
the next nap lots of stairs it's all not
strategies with Andy man can I just ask
you one thing both of you have you're
you're you're very beautiful women you
men you've got long eyelashes I'm that
is the look that you've decided to to go
with 24/7 anywhere what does that do for
you the long eyelashes it's still pretty
I don't feel complete even if my face is
all done I don't feel complete without
my eyelashes in time I think you would
yeah yeah do you think we could put some
eyelashes on you you would look sexy
that that's all as you have now heard my
sex life is pretty crazy oh you're
coming over here for this
we're gonna go on this side all right I
told you I'm happy to keep those fake
eyelashes their eyeballs close my eye
hook you don't close your eyeballs you
you're dry you you draw the leg over the
ocular jelly you know that okay I'm
becoming aroused all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
this feels so right to me
[Applause]
Andy what do you think should I just
commit to this every night it looks like
some goth butterflies and land
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that would be good you just put on and
go to the grocery store you know where
these around town in it someone takes
the photo great if I was like no picture
leave me alone me and my privacy I don't
know how fast was I going officer
traffic tickets this way can we swing a
deal
[Applause]